uh and just a bit more update we're
getting from the government spokesman
about what's happened in terms of this
evacuation we're hearing that the
evacuation of British Nationals was
authorized by the Prime Minister late
last night according to Downing Street
it's something that the Prime Minister
and foreign secretary had been working
on for some time apparently a little
over 2 000 people have now registered uh
in Sudan as British Nationals with the
foreign office Downing Street said so
one would assume that those are the ones
who wish to leave and UK passport
holders are being evacuated from Sudan
are going to be first taken to Cyprus
before they will be brought back to the
UK
Cyprus will help facilitate their onward
travel and also they've said that these
evacuation flights will go on as long as
possible but bearing in mind the risk to
both UK personnel and British Nationals
and as we were telling you a short while
ago there's going to be a cobra meeting
this afternoon to discuss it all further
well our Middle East correspondent
Alistair bunkel has the latest from RAF
at criteri in Cyprus where there's very
citizens are going first
I know of two aircraft who that have
left here uh earlier this morning the
first was a C-130 uh Hercules a smaller
transport plane that landed at the
Airfield just north of hartum wasn't on
the ground for very long turned round is
on its way back it's just crossed out of
Sydney's airspace and there's somewhere
over Egypt on its way back here now I
believe that was probably putting down
some staff possibly border four star
foreign foreign office officials
probably some security protection as
well I guess in order to coordinate on
the ground everybody who will be looking
to get out the second aircraft is a
slightly larger Transport Aircraft an
a400 an Airbus which I think probably
judging by what it took off from here
and the flight time will have quite
recently landed at that air base now
that one will I believe be the first to
pick up britons who are wanting to be
evacuated from Sudan a
apart from that those are the two
aircraft that we know of and only one of
them is picking up civilians at this
stage which you know won't be nearly
enough we know there's around 4 000
British passport holders in Sudan what
we don't know is how many of them want
to get out some of them might possibly
want to stay for various personal
reasons and we don't know how many have
also decided to take matters into their
own hands and make the roads Journey
down to Port Sudan which is a long
journey and a very dangerous one at the
moment but once they reach Port Sudan
they could be in some relative safety
and look to get out of the country by
sea and that is why the RAF sent a very
large C-17 Transport Aircraft down to
Port Sudan late yesterday afternoon with
a recce team on board to see what the
options are there and they're looking at
moving raw naval ships that are in the
Middle East some of them in the Gulf
down towards Port Sudan for a possible
sea evacuation so that's what's going on
at the moment they're taking advantage
of this 72-hour ceasefire window that is
in play the moment that is going to be
very fragile we've seen attempts at
ceasefires before none of them have held
quite as long as this I know we're only
a few hours into it but such is the
fragility of the situation it could
collapse at any moment and so that is
why literally every hour counts